let's talk about the business of the
budget an infrastructure another
Washington elements with senior
political analyst Brit Hume good evening
Brit hi Brett you know the budget and
the the thought that Republicans are in
a different place now than they were in
recent years about concern about
spending and and some criticism from
more conservative members like Jim
Jordan saying that this is just spending
you know through the roof well it
certainly looks that way and that's the
criticism you're gonna hear there might
be very much bread of what happened back
during the early years of the Reagan
administration when the president pushed
through an enormous tax cut and at the
same time a great deal of money was
being spending to build up the American
military at the time of course the big
driver of domestic spending was not the
discretionary stuff that we're arguing
about now but then as now it was
entitlement spending and the president
made an effort I took a stab at trying
to get something seriously done about
that he didn't really succeed and no one
really ever has since and the president
of course in this instance has basically
taken it off the table so we are
fighting here about about whether it's
possible to raise military spending
which nearly every Republican and
everyone in the military says is
absolutely necessary at this stage
without also raising domestic spending
to bring along Democratic votes and
those House members Jim Jordan and the
others who are criticizing this deal
have yet to explain how it is possible
when you need 60 votes in the United
States Senate and you only have 51
Republicans then you can push through
higher military spending without also
raising domestic spending and of course
Jordan and the others all voted for the
big tax cut which everybody in the
Republican Party seems to want but it
does leave us in a situation where we're
having this having this argument over
overspending and and you know when they
exit when they can explain when the
critics can explain how it is that that
we can spend the money on the military
and not give up someone domestic they
need they need to say how that would
work I think the cameras in agreement
they're nodding up and down Brett and
let me ask you cameras and
with me let me ask you about your
perception of this White House issue and
the Rob Porter situation how it was
handled how how messy it is now and
where do you think it goes well it
really hasn't been handled so much its
bungled bungled in the sense that the
necessary information apparently never
reached the people who needed to decide
that maybe having this guy around was
not a good idea considering the charges
against him I can certainly understand
how one would be sympathetic to the idea
that if somebody is merely accused as
has been suggested in this case that he
shouldn't automatically be drummed out
of polite society but of course in this
instance we had not one woman alleging
abuse but two ex-wives and on top of
that their photographs which should
raise a lot of alarms and apparently the
alarms even weren't properly raised or
they or they or the people who should
have heard the alarms didn't respond to
them and then of course you have the
problem that the President himself in
responding to this has been defensive of
his now departed aide understandable
perhaps on a human level but he is yet
to say anything the indicate he has much
sympathy for the women involved which I
think will feed into the narrative this
guy's some kind of a misogynist whether
that's true or not it certainly makes it
look that way so he went through but
you're right he hasn't he hasn't he
personally hasn't said a word he did is
you're correct I heard Sarah Sanders say
that today that she was speaking for him
when he expressed concern but there's no
substitute in certain cases from the
word coming from the principle himself
and quickly do you think White House
chief of staff John Kelly's in jeopardy
here no I'm well I'd be surprised if you
were and if the press if the president
is chafing under the restrictive
operation that Kelly is I think wisely
imposed on the White House he might use
this as an excuse to get rid of him but
I don't think that's going to happen and
I think it would be a very serious loss
to the nation if it did because the
discipline that has been imposed under
Kelly has been very badly needed and
things have gone better since he was
that since he got there Brett as always
thank you